thank you and thanks for inviting me to
participate in this boot camp what I
plan to do is give a very very basic
introduction of thalamus and cortex and
in fact the outline for the talk will
start off with very basic understanding
or description of the properties of
thalamus and then I will talk about the
division of thalamus into corn matrix I
won't have a lot to say about this but I
think it's important to bring this off
that least officially about talk about
the circuitry within thalamus and some
of the synaptic properties that are
involved
switch to cortex again this is going to
be a very brief superficial beautiful
cortex at least the beginner subtypes
layers and columns and cortex area
specializations and cortex and I'll
switch to the relationship between
cortex and thalamus and feedback layer
6-quart Atlantic Organization this is a
very poorly understood pathway it's a
massive pathway and I'll try to explain
why it's so difficult to study it and
then if time permitting and I'm very
flexible about timing here I'll get into
more complicated stuff I think it goes
without saying that you should feel free
to interrupt me at any time when asked
to be patient because I don't hear that
like so I may have to ask you to speak
up a repeat but we'll get through that
okay to start with the thalamus on this
is would be an early embryonic view of
the brain through the third ventricle
and this has the region where thalamus
is going to evolve from there's a reason
called that epithalamus which is not a
particular interest here but this is
what's known as the dorsal thalamus
because it's found more dorsally and
that's the reason for the name and this
is where all the relay nuclei
exists that is this is where all the
regions all the subgroups that project
the cortex are going to evolve
developing
but there's also a ventral thalamus
which includes the thalamic reticular
nucleus a region of the lateral
geniculate that is really not going to
be much important for what I have to say
and sometimes a region called the zone
insert is included there but the main
area of ventral thalamus it's important
is the thalamic reticular nucleus to put
this in context the thalamus is a parent
structure right at the midline right in
the middle of your brain and each one of
these is about the size of a walnut so
again this is a view of the brain
lateral surface medial surface is the
thalamus and these are the sort of a
cartoon view of the thalamus this would
be the left thalamus back to front and
this shows the dorsal thalamus with all
the relay nuclei and this would be the
thalamic reticular nucleus which sits
sort of as a shield up against the
lateral surface it's pulled away and cut
off so you can see the relay nuclei so
this is where the cells are projected
cortex limb the thalamic reticular
nucleus does not have cells that protect
the cortex instead all of these cells
are inhibitory they're GABAergic and
they project into the main loop VI the
relay nuclei to innervate relay cells
and inhibit them provide powerful and
efficient of relay cells a couple of
additional points here one is that all
cortical areas as far as we know receive
a thalamic input this is a general
property of thalamus and cortex and
second virtually all information
reaching cortex must pass through
thalamus this is a very strategically
located and organized structure
basically information from the periphery
that comes in has a bottleneck through
thalamus and we think that almost plays
a crucial role in things like attention
meaning that it can block the flow of
information particularly if you're not
attending to it and one of the roles of
thalamus is to act as a gate to control
what information reaches cortex and what
doesn't
yes
other cortical inputs like from other
areas of cortex to do what passing
through the elements yes I'll get to
that if I don't ask the question towards
a different place here is that better
can you turn the volume of the mic up
back there I'll try to speak up I'll
speak louder okay so what I want to
spend just a few minutes is talking
about the core matrix division of
thalamus this these terms won't mean
much adieu till I talk about them there
if we make cuts through the brain in
this sup in a cup what's called a
coronal plane you can see thalamic
nuclei here the ones in outline in green
are part of the core
Philomath cortical system and there are
ones in white that aren't and a feature
of core pathways as they project each
one of these nuclei to the relatively
limited region of cortex and mostly
innervate the middle layers the matrix
cells are located throughout the lovest
concentrated in these red zone but found
in every single fill a McNew clea so
you'll notice that what we call a core
nucleus also has a smattering of matrix
cells these cells are very de fiercely
projecting instead of being topographic
they project very widely through cortex
and they mostly innervate layer one
another feature of matrix system is that
these cells also intervene the basal
ganglion amygdala these that are made
only cortex so it's not known whether
individual cells branch to do both or
whether they're separate populations and
in fact one of the problems with the
matrix is that although we think it's a
very important system this is about all
we know about it
it's thought to play some general rule
and overall arousal it used to be called
the reticular activating system but
frankly we know very little about the
cell properties that give rise to it and
the synaptic properties up in cortex
because innervating layer one provides a
very difficult system to study and when
I talk about the layering of cortex off
I may come back to that this is all I'm
gonna have to say about matrix I'm just
alerting you that these pathways do
exist I'm sure they're important and the
frustration is even though they were
identified in the 1950s we haven't
invest our knowledge of them very much
at all
so to concentrate on the core pathways
that we know a lot about and talk about
basic circuitry there are you able to
hear me in the back ok so this is a
section through the thalamus through the
somatosensory thalamus in this example
and this is the TRN more laterally this
is medial this is lateral this is the
TRN this thin band of cells and the
stain here is for gaba so when you see
dark staining here you you have cell
bodies and terminals and that that
Express gaba so you're seeing inhibitory
systems in the thalamus and you see
there's lots of GABAergic staining in
the relay nuclei here's the LGN as well
as a thalamic reticular nucleus so if we
take a region like this and blow it up
this is what you see flap a particular
nucleus has fairly large cells and 100
percent of them are gabbard that's why
there's thin dark here if you look in
the main relay nuclei we also have
GABAergic cells are smaller and these
are the inter neurons that is they don't
protect the cortex but they provide
local circuitry and they innervate the
relay cells these are the larger cells
here they're unstained because they're
not GABAergic they don't use gab as in
our transmitter they use glutamate and
and what we have are two types of
inhibitory neurons and both of them
concentrate their input on to the relay
cell
why we have two systems and what the
difference between them isn't entirely
clear although there's some differences
in anatomy that provides some insights
but one thing you can see here if you
can imagine if these GABAergic cells are
very active they will so inhibit the
relay cells that they can relay no
information to cortex the gateway
through thalamus is closed
conversely if these cells themselves are
inhibited and not firing very much the
gate is open and the relay to cortex is
allowed and you have the gate open or
closed and various positions in between
gating we think is one of the really
important roles of thalamus but there
are many other roles as well some of
which I'll have a chance to talk about
another's I won't okay that's a very
simple but straightforward I think
function for thalamus now if we put all
this in a cartoon circuit we see the
following this is a relay Sun these are
three imaginary three relay nuclei could
be LGN somatosensory auditory and each
of the trna is also divided up into
zones that reflect a relationship with
each of the relay nuclei so we have
inhibitory input to the relay cells from
these local inter neurons we also have
inhibitory input from the thalamic
reticular nucleus the relay cells
project up to quartets
but one and root they passed through the
TRN and they provide collateral input
this excitatory onto the TRN cells we
also have a feedback from cortex this
feedback that shown here actually
emanates from layer six the bottom layer
of cortex Oh more to say about this and
as these axons come down they branch
individual axons branch to innervate
relay cells and also the local inter
neurons and these cells are
glutamatergic these cells are going to
motoric these cells are GABAergic those
are the main cell types we haven't
now to complete the circuitry of
thalamus there is another major input
the comes from cells scattered
throughout the brainstem we call this
the green stem reticular formation has
lots of names I don't want to get into
confusing terminology but if we took a
section here will see that these cells
project very diffusely and widely to
thalamus some of them reach cortex and
through that cross section these are the
cells that would project the cortex just
to give you an example they're scattered
throughout the brainstem they don't form
into very nice nuclei so if we put all
this in the context and use the lateral
geniculate nucleus as an example this is
the relay of retinal informational
cortex we see the retinal input to relay
cells inhibit excitatory input this
shows the transmitters used the
projection up to mostly middle layers of
cortex these are the showing the
inhibitory input from the reticular
cells and the inter neurons going to
relay cells this is the feedback from
layer six branching axons that innervate
in the inhibitory cells as well as the
relay cells and what this tells you is
that because these are all excitatory
synapses is that this pathway can
provide both direct excitation relay
cells but also die synaptic inhibition
and so the net result when relay cells
is quite difficult to understand and I
will spend more time talking about this
on the other hand the input from the
brain stem reticular formation also
through branching axons interface all of
these but it does something very tricky
and it feels if you'll notice here it
provides excitation relay cells but the
same axons using the same transmitter
mostly asset of choline but others are
can be inhale inhibits the inhibitory
neurons and that means that while these
cells are active you not only get direct
excitation of relay cells but you get a
removal of inhibition by inhibiting the
inhibitory cells that's what you and
imagine is and when these cells are
active the gate is going to be open when
these cells are
inactive the inhibitory interneurons are
allowed to become activated the relay
cells are less depolarized and so the
gate would be closed is that clear to
everybody else okay question is how this
is done so this is the example of the
retina innovating the LGN the main
difference between the LGN and any other
ceramic nucleus is the input to be
relayed the other non retinal inputs are
pretty much conserved throughout the
thalamus and and across species there
are differences to be sure between
nuclei on between species but I'm gonna
ignore those the first approximation you
have the same non retinal innervation in
the circuitry again what's different is
what's relayed so if this were their
somatosensory thalamus this would be the
medial lemniscus providing somatosensory
information and so on so again how does
the these cholinergic cells mainly do
this trick the answer is that they
activate receptors that are postsynaptic
that are quite different and I'm going
to take a little detour to talk about
postsynaptic receptors because they
think they're generally more important
than appreciated both in thalamic
circuitry and cortical circuitry and I
think this is an important issue for
modelers to take up there are two kinds
of receptor basically one type is called
an ionotropic receptor the examples I'll
use are the AMPA receptor and the gaba-a
receptor now for the AMPA receptor when
when the neurotransmitter glutamate
binds to the receptor which is a
molecule in the membrane this is the
outside the cell this is inside the cell
you get a very fast conformational
change that opens the pore an a sodium
or calcium channel it opens up and this
happens very quickly because the channel
is as part of the protein that's
affected by the by the transmitter and
once this opens sodium or or calcium in
some cases can flow into the cell so you
get a net flow of positive ions into the
cell because of the
of the concentration gradient and that
means itself becomes more depolarized
inside with these positive ions and you
get a very fast epsp it's called
excitatory postsynaptic potential as a
result of this the other main kind of
ionotropic receptor is the GABA a
receptor it's a very similar thing gaba
binds to the receptor a chloride channel
opens in this case and now a negative
ion goes inside the cell and that's
going to hyperpolarize it well this is
all contrasted to what we call
metabotropic receptors and they're a
bunch of them we have them for glutamate
a little choline or adrenaline dopamine
and so on and they mostly involved
potassium channels so in this example
where the potassium channel is open we
have a very complex receptor much more
complicated much more complicated than
for an entropic receptor so it includes
what's called a g-protein when the
transmitter binds to the receptor the
g-protein is released and swims through
the membrane to interact with another
protein called an affected protein and
this little leads to an explosive chain
of reactions that are called second
messenger pathways but two biochemical
reactions are set off some of them can
affect many things in the cell besides
ion channels they can affect even gene
expression so when you activate
metabotropic receptors you get much more
possibly than just changes in
postsynaptic potentials and that's not
very well explored anyway one of the
things that happens is in this case of a
sodium potassium channel that's open
allowing sodium potassium to leak out of
the cell is now closed and this prevents
the leakage of potassium allowing a
buildup of potassium I and said
otherwise wouldn't be there and that's a
depolarization
but notice the time course this is a
very fast time course these
depolarizations can last hundreds of
milliseconds to several seconds so it's
a very slow prolonged process and this
is what we get for a type of
metabotropic glutamate receptor it's
called group 1 and also the m1 type of
muscarinic receptor then as you
for a semicolon we have the opposite as
well let's have a tropic receptors that
when activated open up a potassium
channel now these positive ions will
flow out of the cell and that's not
leads to hyperpolarization because you
get less a negative that's positivity
inside the cell the same kind of time
course this we see for Group two
metabotropic glutamate receptors the m2
type of muscarinic receptor for us
little choline and the gap would be
receptor notice one point I want to
emphasize as a glutamate when it
encounters when it encounters this kind
of receptor can hyperpolarize so
glutamate can be inhibitory and we see
about a lot in cortex in particular most
people think of cortical inhibition as
only gap merging but a lot of it is it
can be glutamatergic as well okay so
what are two other things about these
receptors that are important the under
tropic receptor because it as a direct
action is very brief these receptors are
found right at the synapse and these are
examples of them the ampa and nmda
receptors leading to the PSP's
acetylcholine has a nicotinic receptor
the sign of tropic leads to an epsp and
gaba as a gate GABA a receptor that
produces an IPS p taba Trepak receptors
seem to be located farther away from the
from the synapse forming an annulus
around it and I'll get back to why that
might be important this operates through
the second messenger system so it's
indirect
it produces prolonged epsps or ipsps
allows hundreds of milliseconds to
several seconds
glutamate activates Group one with AB
atrophic receptors to produce epsps or
group two for ipsps acetylcholine also
can do epsps or ipsps depending on the
receptor and the gaba B receptor gives
you a long I pass P the location here
can be either okay depending on whether
the receptor postsynaptic is Group one
or group two
yeah but as far as we know is always
inhibitory oh thank you what is the
proportion of excitatory glutamate
receptors versus inhibitory great
question I wish we knew so what I can
tell you I don't think I have a slide
that shows us is you can use immune
cytokines tree to see the extent to
which you get staining of these kinds of
receptors and thalamus and cortex and
the cortex in particular you see a lot
of both types but in most rudimentary
inputs and cortex and thalamus activate
one of these but I don't think we know
enough to know what the relative numbers
here are the relative strength so you
get both kinds approximately there is
definitely more of Group 1 vs. where we
don't know if I were to guess I'd say
more group on the group 2 based on what
we've seen but it's not a very
quantitative approach certainly get a
lot of both because the location of the
receptors this tells us something about
the sensitivity of these receptors to
activation of the presynaptic axon so
because these autotrophic receptors
right at the synapse any frequency of
firing here even a single action
potential can activate them so when this
axon is just firing at a very low rate
or a very high rate you're gonna get
ionotropic responses but because of the
lateral location of the metabotropic
receptors we think this is the reason
you don't start activating them until
this axon starts firing at a relatively
higher rate roughly 10 Hertz or so
because you need to eject more
transmitter takes more transmitter
released here to get to these receptors
we think that's the reason for this but
this is interesting because it means
that when you have postsynaptic
receptors of both types only then a
tropic receptors are going to be
activated when the cells not when this
input is not doing what but when the
input is doing something really
important and gets excited then you
bring in the metallic
responses any questions about this so
far okay
so if we go back just to review very
quickly the muscarinic receptors for a
sort of choline the m1 receptors
produces an epsp m2 an IPS B and
prolonged one at that and so if we go
back to this circuit the axon branch
that innervates the relay cells from
these cholinergic inputs activates m1
receptors and that and that gives you
the epsp on the relay cells but the
branches carrying the same transmitter
then invade the inhibitory cells the
GABAergic cells activate m2 receptors
leaning to ipsps and shutting down these
cells and that's how this input does
that nice trick and again it means when
these cells are active the gate is open
when these cells are inactive the gate
is relatively closed there's a nice
example of this from a paper from stereo
on many many years ago I forget what
year this was published but at least
thirty years old what he's done here is
he's taken a cat and he stuck an
electrode a gross electrode into the LGN
or the visual relay and recorded the
response to electrically stimulating the
optical nerves and what you see here is
this complex waveform when you record
with this recruit electrode and I'll
take you through it this first wave is
the presynaptic action potentials coming
into the thalamus this is the post
synaptic response and you can tell
whether the cat is alert sleeping or
drowsy by measuring the EEG at the same
time you notice when the cat is alert
there's a strong post synaptic response
the gate is open when the cat is asleep
the gate is closed there's no effect on
the retinal output because the retinas
not influenced by levels of alertness
the animals drowsy you get a more
variable response and what we know is
that those brain stem cells are very
active during alert behavior and are
shut down during sleep and during drowsy
periods they are intermittent yeah
preventing of this burette is really
being a universal gate where everything
is closed down and shut down as I'm
generalizing it's more complicated I'm
generalizing and I'm only talking about
the cholinergic effects which we know
best
there are nor adrenergic summed up on
number nerds you can put serotonergic so
there there are a lot of different
transmitter systems used and and which
ones are active in a particular nucleus
very so the LGN for the sensory ones
seem to be dominated by cholinergic
input which I'm talking about here
there's there's range for a lot more
variable effects that aren't really very
well explored but most of what we know
about the elements comes from studies of
the visual thalamus and when it comes to
this kind of thing at something to
extrapolate but we really don't have the
evidence that this is true for all
thymic nuclei but something like this is
very likely any other questions ok
y'all switched the cortex again this is
very superficial they're actually three
kinds of cortex paleo cortex which is
the olfactory cortex
Archy cortex which is a hippocampal
formation I'm gonna talk only about
neocortex there's other course areas
like I don't really have time to go into
and most of the studies that I Navy will
be familiar with are really mostly
concentrating on the neocortex this is
them the names imply that this is the
newest part of our cortex to evolve the
most recently evolved cell types we've
heard about South eyes before if you're
a splitter there are probably as many as
50 different cell types and cortex to
simplify things I'm gonna lump things
horribly and talk about only four cell
types but you have to just keep in mind
that each of these cell types I'm
talking about has lots of subclasses the
most prominent cell in cortex have
already heard a lot about this is the
pyramidal cell this has shown so that
the top of cortex would be up here the
bottom is down here the pyramidal cell
is so called because it's a cell body is
shaped like a pyramid roughly with the
apex pointing up towards the surface of
the cortex
it has basal dendrites and apical
dendrites and these apical dendrites can
reach the court of the surface with lots
of spines on them the pyramidal cell
some of the pyramidal cells not all of
them represent the main output of cortex
the main e friends so these axons will
project into the white matter project
other cortical areas and in some cases
projects up cortically but it's
important to keep in mind that they also
provide a lot of local innervation
through these collaterals so they're not
just Ephrem cells interneurons come in
two shapes we're calling them stellate
cells are smooth and there's spiny as
the names imply these are thought to be
exclusively inhibitory interneurons and
these
are excited to re-enter neurons of
course he's particularly particularly
inhibitory ones come in many exotic
shapes but these are in these but by
calling them in turn neurons they don't
have axons that project out of cortex to
subcortical structures and very rarely
very form within cortex final cell type
which we which I won't spend much time
talking about it's called a fusiform
cell it has a bipolar dendritic tree
this also has axons that can leave
cortex as well as the pyramidal cell and
the orientation of the bipolar dendritic
tree can be any orientation this is
vertical it could be horizontal it could
be anywhere in between so there's the
four main cell types again what each of
them have lots of variations that I'm
not going to go into how do they fit
with layers well I think you all know
that we have layers of cortex and what
you see here are three cartoon examples
these represent Golgi and Pregnant's
you've heard about the Golgi stain that
qahal made famous this stain really
picks out a very small percentage of
cells and stains them entirely so you
get the cell body the dendrite the axon
if it stained every cell this would just
be a black mass so it's a nice thing it
randomly picks out cells and we have no
idea what the rationale for cells that
picks out is this is a nissl stain that
stains every cell body every neuron but
not much of the dendrites and not the
axon so you can see where all the cells
are this is a myelin stain that stains
myelinated fibers now these cells are
arranged in layers the top layer is
called the molecular plex formers on you
layer layer one it has very few cells in
it it's mostly a synaptic region where
synapses are formed between apical
dendrites of these pyramidal cells and
fibers for running in layer one which
mostly come from other cortical areas
but some from matric cells in
layer two is called the external
granular layer because it's comprised
mostly of granule cells or stellate
cells
I'm sorry Stelling cells layer three is
external pyramidal layer comprised
mostly of pyramidal cells we have the
internal granular layer or internal
stellate cells we have the internal
pyramidal layer these are the largest
pyramidal cells are found and this is
the other layer that provides much of
the input out of cortex to subcortical
structures and finally layer six which
is a multi form layer having a lot of
these unusual cells that are bipolar
type cells but even though I said that
this this layers 2 and 4 mostly stellate
and 3 & 5 are mostly pyramidal all cell
types are found in all layers except
layer 1 so you have pyramidal cells and
layers 2 & 4 you have stellate cells and
layers 3 & 5 but layers to inform mostly
for us stellate 3 & 5 are mostly
pyramidal no early anatomist in the 30s
looking at slots material like this
immediately saw what turns out to be
important that the especially when you
look at the initial stains the cells
seem to be arranged in columns with gaps
between and those gaps are filled by
mullen ated axons running up and down
the column and columnar organization of
cortex which is first described by bob
castle and later demonstrated more
convincingly by Hubel and Wiesel turns
out to be an important feature of cortex
we believe a general canonical feature
and this is an example from a paper by
Hubel and Wiesel that shows what the
columns mean they're roughly these
columns are roughly half a millimeter
across and what they're showing here is
they put an electrode through the visual
cortex and this electrode counted
encountered single cells and each cell
they plotted the receptive field for
what they found that the receptive
fields of the cells as long as you
stayed within a column fell on top of
each other so they were representing the
same point of visual space but more
interestingly they have the same
orientation
like Tiffany let's say horizontal in
this case stayed within a column all the
cells were interested in the same
orientation if you cut across columns
you saw that the orientation specificity
of the cells in the column
shifted gradually around the clock and
their point was that each column takes a
part of visual space in this example and
is interested in the main features a
particular feature that it is involved
in analyzing in this case orientation
there are columns we think for direction
for spatial frequency for all sorts of
things where we just Eve would come in
where does the output go and where's
layer one where we're getting way ahead
of me okay I'll get to that get that
soon I think so the columnar
organization again is a key feature of
cortex and we think that if we
understand how a column functions that
we will understand the great part of a
great great insight into cortical
functioning I will say that the
connections within a column are mostly
up and down the column you have
relatively few connections running
horizontally in cortex okay to answer
your question let's look at the inputs
to a cortical column from other cortical
areas they terminate mostly in layer 2
from thalamus core regions mostly in
layer 4 but also some in layer 6 the
matrix to layer 1 pasta which is a
structure I'm really not going to say
much about it's a thin layer of cells
that sits below cortex innervates layer
6 but ignore that we get lots of
modulatory inputs that vary diffusely
innervate cortex and innervate pretty
much all layers the base of forebrain
which provides a lot of this provides
cholinergic input to all of these layers
for the outputs if you want to send
information in another cortical area it
comes mostly out of layer 3 layer 5
provides the main sub cortical
projection too many site switching
style of us and also spinal-cord almost
any brainstem nucleus that is going to
get an input from cortex that will get
it from layer five a layer six also
provides input the thalamus and I'll
talk about the difference between these
two inputs the thalamus and then we get
that classroom also so classroom forms
this loop that is not well understood
and I'm not gonna have any more to say
about it
these laminar patterns are meant to be a
simplification when they represent the
main tendencies for the relationships of
layers to inputs and outputs but there
are exceptions for instance princess
thalamus probably innervates all layers
and you can get outputs from other to
other cortical areas from other layers
as well but what's interesting about
this generalization is that the upper
layers layers 2 & 3 in particular we're
interested in communicating with other
cortical areas getting its input here
and its output there the bottom layers
are mostly communicating with
subcortical sites and that's a
generalization we can make about cortex
so this is how the layering generally
applies to inputs and outputs and if we
consider a single column well start in
layer 4 because arbitrarily because this
is where most lemak inputs come in layer
4 cells project all this is going to be
within a column up the layers 2 3 mostly
you go from layers to 3 down to layer 5
also down a layer 6 layer 5 you also get
down to layer 6 and from layer 6 you
close the loop and get back up to layer
4 imagine all this is within a column
and again this is a simplification but
it's a useful one to start thinking
about the how cortical columns are
organized yeah you have to speak up
well each column is about a half a
millimeter across so depending on what
the area of cortex is the surface area
you can roughly figure out how many
columns at that area you will have and
the size of a column we don't know we
don't have a lot of data on this but the
size of a column is pretty much fixed
throughout cortex we think so a larger
cortical area will have more columns and
a smaller one have fewer columns single
column yeah right so if we go let me go
back to the previous slide so in this
example a single column of the cells in
a column can protect other cortical
areas very very far away including to
the other side the other hemisphere and
the same for the input so they can
communicate over quite a large distance
the modulation was due to input from the
elements how do you how do we know that
that modulation of the awake and so if
we talk about that that the slide I
showed that showed that the input
through LG n was being shut down we
think that's mostly because of activity
in the brainstem inputs the thalamus
that are correlated to whether the
animals awake or asleep so let me go
through that again very quickly the
animals awake the CoreLogic impetus from
brain stem are very active and we know
that they will excite relay cells and
inhibit their inhibitory inputs dis
inhibit them so they brought the
exciting and disinhibited them which
made some very responsive to visual
input the gate is open when those cells
shut down and they shut down when the
animal goes to sleep you remove a direct
excitation of relay cells and you also
remove the disinhibition you allow the
inhibition to take over the relay cells
are relatively hyperpolarized and they
don't respond to the rental input
anymore so we think that's the simple
answer to that question there's so much
going on could it be some other pathways
as well yes I can we can't rule that out
but let's just say that that's our
understanding at present for how this is
marking there isn't put the input from
cortex can also have an effect on this
but I'm talking about overall general
effects to shut things down you can shut
things and that that would be a global
nonprofit graphic effect the layer six
input and I hope the gut tunas can do
this in the highly topographic manner
maybe that's what you're asking about so
you can in what I've talked about was
turning was opening or closing the gates
throughout the thalamus in a very global
manner but there are pathways allow you
to do it very specifically for single
cells even small groups of relay cells
and I hope to get to that okay
eriell specializations now I talked
about a general cortical type but back
to there are many types of cortical
areas and this show oops
this shows a lumping approach that only
has five types type three is the general
area area of cortex it has all six
layers very clearly demonstrated part
five is called a granular cortex because
of the granular layers to inform highly
represented lots of Stelling cells not
very many pyramidal cells and we see
that associated with primary sensory
areas the visual cortex primary visual
cortex auditory cortex somatosensory
cortex the other end we have a granular
cortex very few Prem very few stellate
cells but lots of pyramidal cells and
this is look this is related to motor
areas of cortex because you have lots of
pyramidal cells lots of outputs and we
have types in between and there have
been attempts to map this out so there
are variations and in some cases it's
hard to see all the layers in the case
of purely sensory or motor cortex for
instance here it's hard to see we're
layer four is but if you use special
staining techniques you can demonstrate
that all these layers actually do exist
are just harder to recognize we think
they're found throughout cortex but most
of our information about quartet about
the columns comes from sensory cortex I
guess like with whiskers for rodents
endless
there's a lot of studies about columns
there's a two calls also a distance a
hippocampus and hippocampus you know I
don't believe so
this is a neocortical property in 19th
century there was a cottage industry
among anatomist largely German anatomist
to see how many different kinds of
cortex they could define just by histor
chemistry and some of them came up with
over 200 and and it's a sum it's a
historical interest to some but the
important map of cortex of all the
quarter corners that is survive today is
called the broadband map and it's
important because only because the
numbers that are used are still applied
today
and so the Broadman defined
fifty-some-odd areas based on these
slight differences in lamination area 17
is striate cortex primary visual cortex
41 and 42 would be the primary auditory
cortical areas we have a motor and
somatosensory areas as well
the only reason why this isn't all
important is because those numbers are
often used and you might want to
understand that when someone says
they're they're looking at the response
as an area 17 you should understand what
were those numbers come from
in some cases like areas 17 the
correlation between the the structure
and the function is pretty clear but a
lot of these areas that Broadman defined
really don't seem very specific
correlate to a functional area so it's
it's use today is not very significant
except for some of these areas
particularly that the find the primary
motor and
three areas that's also valuable for
neurosurgeons of they say I found the
tumor in area 46 it helps identify to
colleague where that tumor is but
otherwise these maps are mostly of
historical interest
in the old days before the 70s we
thought there was primary sensory cortex
let me go back a bit primary sensory
cortices some primary motor cortex and
everything in between was called
Association cortex because we didn't
know what it was it turns out there's
probably very little association cortex
at all because we now know from mapping
studies that started in the 70s and
continue today that the back half of
cortex is almost all purely visual we
have lots of somatic motor and auditory
areas and this is a very old map taken
from the 1970s I believe as more areas
are studied with more sophisticated
techniques we find that most of these
areas of cortex have a relatively
specific sensory or motor function the
main areas that could be called
Association would be frontal areas that
don't seem to help that kind of sensory
or motor function and this is a map a
very useful map that's very important
from David Van Essen and colleagues they
took monkey's brain and with computer
and help they unfolded it and so this
would be the lateral surface the medial
surface and this would be unfolded and
this is v1 or area 17 what's interesting
when you look at the map of a monkey or
and this will also in a part of the
human is that the back half is almost
all visual there are 30 some-odd visual
areas here's the auditory regions
there's the somatic motor regions so
most of the cortex and these maps again
are about 30 years old most of cortex
have fairly specific sensory or motor
function in the case of the visual areas
it's believed that there are this would
be another way of looking at it the
connections again from a David venison's
lab go through thalamus and and they
arranged all these areas into
hierarchies the ideas and information is
flowing up these hierarchies and they
identified five or six parallel
hierarchies with five or six different
levels
has been a very influential map I'm
going to make some modifications of it
if I have time one thing that's
interesting is the pulvinar which is a
very large Islamic nucleus in this scale
has this sort of arrows pointing up Kirt
kind of with with I could put questions
mark this here but I'm going to try to
put this into the scheme or more firmly
so this is still pretty much our current
view of cortical processing particularly
in sensory areas like federal court that
said it's hierarchical and you go from
basic information analysis to more and
more complex sophisticated things up
these several area up these several
streams been involved in this was
actually done by hand but the ones they
do now okay so I'm gonna switch gears
now if there any questions up to this
point I'm going to talk about the layer
six feedback he'll does it differ
between humans and more primitive from
great question how how do we relate all
this to humans a lot of this work is
done at a wide range of animals
including some humans and could we go
for mice through carnivores like cats
and ferrets to monkeys and then humans
and by comparing these these different
species we try to get a sense of what
our general properties of the mammalian
cortex and those will apply to humans as
opposed to things that are unique to
each species you try to sort that out by
looking at
the information and lots of species one
of the problems today is that when I
started out many years ago the species
that were studied there must have been a
dozen different species which gave you a
pretty good platform for trying to
understand what is general form in
mammals and what is not now we're down
to two
monkeys and mice and they're very far
apart so we're and we're having trouble
now figuring out what's what's general
what applies to mammals
and there are forty humans I believe I
think this is correct that what I've
been talking about so far in what I will
continue to talk about is an attempt to
pick out the properties that are general
mammalian properties of a body humans
but we're not we're not on very firm
footing because we just don't have
enough comparative data and the human
data is mostly largely I should say
limited to imaging like MRI you can't do
these kinds of experiments obviously in
humans to get those kind of data so
again we we think this is what I'm
talking about is related to humans but
that's that's a big problem yep where is
the information from the different
sensory areas fused that's a good
question to it we used to be taught in
the old days that's what Association
cortex was doing but there are areas
that have been identified that are
multi-sensory and this is where it's
happening the superior colliculus which
is a subcortical structure is an
important structure for this and and is
a very old structure and was as an area
that used the the that is used for that
in non-mammalian vertebrates like birds
and reptiles and so on and that's still
true in in mammals but their cortical
areas that have been identified that are
multi-sensory and I think that's an
important point because most of us who
study sensory systems study a single
system we consecrate on the visual
system or the somatosensory system and
so on that's not the way our brain works
we're using multi-sensory integration
all the time when you think about it
imagine you see a flock of birds flying
overhead if you just have vision you
might not know what they were but you
listen to them at the same time and you
hear whether they hung
or they whatever abduct us whack and and
by putting multi-sensory information
together you immediately identify what
you're dealing with and this is what we
do all the time but people don't study
that very much as very few labs that
actually study multi-sensory integration
okay I want to talk now about this layer
six feedback and you see one of the
problems here is that the feedback can
either directly excite or indirectly
inhibit and if this weather circuit
you'd wonder what the heck is going on
with relay cells when I when these cells
are active you do both and that what
seem to not be very interesting so
here's what the circuit could look like
what we're going to do it at a
single-cell level it will directly
excite this relay cell and indirectly
inhibited and the change in membrane
potential here if these were balanced
would be zero and you might think that
was a useless thing but work done by out
Larry Abbott's lab chance at all paper
or some time ago showed that when you
have balanced activity doesn't have to
be balanced but even if it were balanced
even though you're not changing membrane
potential you're changing the input
resistance of the cell and other factors
that affect the gain of synaptic
transmission of other inputs so if this
were a genetic cell the retinal input
the gain of the retina geniculate the
synapse the size of the epsp would be
greatly reduced if this circuitry
activated them so it's a convenient
useful way to control gain of synaptic
transmission having shown this this is a
different kind of circuit using the same
elements and actually we have evidence
from a number of labs including ours
that suggests that this is actually not
just common that may be the dominant way
things are organized and you see how
different it is when this cell is active
you don't have balance in abyssion and
excitation going in all cells some cells
are excited and some cells are inhibited
you see how different these two circuits
are
okay and again we think this is more
common but both probably exist this is
not a homogeneous pathway but there's a
problem here and I'm going to try to
that I have a difficult time coming up
on way to explain this so please ask
questions if it's not clear let's
imagine that the circuit is really based
like this and we have lots of cells that
are doing this at the single cell level
when any one of these cells is active
some relay cells will be excited others
will be inhibited but the techniques we
use to study this pathway are limited
because we don't activate single cells
and record from single cells instead we
excite or inhibit whole groups now if
you look at the way this is organized if
you were to excite all of these even
with modern techniques that use things
like channelrhodopsin the enemies ava's
that all of these cells would be excited
and inhibited is that clear to everybody
you know at the same cell level it's all
going to look like this when in fact if
you had pattern activity evasion spatial
pattern you get a very different
response down here and this is an
important proviso for most experiments
that are being done when we talk about
knocking out a pathway through lesions
or chemical ways of reducing all these
cells or activating them even modern
techniques we're not seeing the actual
way the circuit is act is behaving and
it's for that reason I think that it's
very difficult to get clear evidence for
what the effect of this pathway is on
relay cells because all the all the
experiments that I know of with very few
exceptions either excite or inhibit
large groups of these cells and you and
you wipe out the beautiful detailed
single-cell circuitry that is really
playing the wrong question that's right
we if you record it layer six they do
see pattern activity right
individual cells active and lots of
other cells not active yeah right so you
can imagine a few health these cells
have very discreet receptive field so if
you are exciting this with a receptive
field that same stimulus would likely
inhibit their neighboring cells because
there's a lot of this direct excitation
and when you get outside the center of
the receptive field you get other kinds
of effects and so there's every reason
to believe that the way this would
respond to visual stimuli would would
would require this kind of detailed
single-cell circuitry but again that's
completely wiped out when you when you
do large-scale excitation or inhibition
how much of this wiring is genetic and
how much is learned there's actually
very little about the cortical input the
thalamus in terms of development the
Rattle input has been studied quite a
bit and there it seems to be and this
was described I think by Jeff that you
get an exuberant initial connection
pattern that is pruned back I don't
think there's we know very much about
how this develops and how much is
genetic okay no other questions about
this I think this is an important
qualification for interpreting many
studies that are done today were you it
doesn't doesn't just apply to this
system imagine that other systems are
organized in this cell specific way if
you do massive inhibition or excitation
of a pathway you both moderate
techniques you run the risk of
obliterating the patterns that are
important one last thing I want to say
about this layer six input so these
layer six cells project down the
thalamus and they can have a pretty
powerful effect because they as I as you
can imagine they can excite the relay
cells and they can influence the local
inhibitory cells and the answer to a
question I think those asked earlier
this is a way that the cortex can very
locally control gating controlling some
relay cells
by inhibiting them and exciting other
relay cells but another important aspect
of these layer six cells that is only
just recently becoming realized is that
the branch of their axon goes up into
layer four to innervate the target cells
of thalamus which means these layer six
cells are pretty interesting because nor
do they affect telemetry flama cortical
transmission at its source but also what
its target so it can affect it at both
places and one thing I'll just throw out
there this input which is glutamatergic
activates mostly route to metabotropic
glutamate receptors here which would
inhibit the cell and so you'd think that
this is a glutamatergic pathway that
will excite the cell in most cases it's
the opposite that last - Guerra going to
layer four so that's coming from the
layer six so it was that you drop it's
an excellent collateral same cells yep
personally how many rows are there well
let's say in a quick we'll call them
orally the way oh those numbers are
known I can't tell you off the top of my
head but I can tell you is for every
retinal axon coming in here there's
about a hundred of these going down and
what that helps the numbers are known
there is a literature on oh I don't
remember the numbers off maybe somebody
in the audience does they also do
functions together there is some other
functions they all have the same set of
do well they have similar receptive
fields are there the same column but
there's more interest in these later six
cells and it turns out that there are at
least three different types of layer six
feedback and if I have chance in the
next star getting into more complicated
stuff I'll bring that up again
so there's heterogeneity here it's not
homogeneous certain properties are
are the same among these cells but they
were different in they and they have
specific kinds of par getting up
specific kinds of relay cells so there's
a lot of specificity here it's been
overlooked I'm going to stop here any
other questions
yo-you shown here the inhibitory signal
inhibiting the the implicit elements
that goes back to the same column is
that the most common case or is yeah so
it's a good question I've been to say
this in I haven't this circuit
represents from cortex to thalamus of
feedback we call it a feedback because
the column is innervated by the relay
cell is the column in which these layer
6 cells are located so this is this is a
classic feedback kind of loop because it
seems that excitation and inhibition die
synaptic etcetera this is not you know I
woke up I don't plan to get in the left
it's a very interesting topic it's
important topic but at this level
there's not much I can say about that
and I might add that in layer 6
depending on the species it's no more
than 50% of the cells were doing this
other layer 6 cells are projecting other
cortical areas so this isn't just layer
6 yeah so getting back something I
wanted to know I've been told by some
people that the input
to the cortex visual input it goes to
layer one
I've been built by others layer three no
no the main if we're talking about
visual cortex from the lateral
geniculate nucleus yes the retinal relay
it's going mostly layer four with some
two layer six the inputs to this is the
core projection there I'm going to get
to this in the second hour I hope there
are some cells on the algae on that are
that our matrix project mostly to layer
one and the cat those are the W cells
and the monkey there was the Konya
cellular cells so that pathway does
exist but as I try to say in the
beginning we don't know much about that
at all that's that's very poorly
understood what its function is I think
we understand a lot more about the
projection the cortex its terminating
mostly in layer four I'm just wearing a
lot of the evidence would be that vision
uses polish so the cortex is constantly
asking questions of the elements of what
what's out there and in that regard from
say whisky which is envisioned but the
idea is that the thalamus plays a role
in phase logics just to read the
stimulus and so it the actual question
is maybe we have to worry about what's
going on to make sense of the very rich
anatomical structures in there if we if
you don't have these functional
questions we going help man
right so maybe we can put that question
aside until I talk about the role of
thalamus in cortical clerical pathways
because I think that's where a lot of
this possibility comes up but it's going
to be mostly speculation
quick time to take a break you say
anything about the relation between
these layers and the layers in the
neural networks that are used to sample
them no easy answer I don't know
neocortex